please explain to us what FTX was what
Alameda was and Sam bankman freed what
he did with these companies so we're
still learning everything right so
everything is based on what we know
right now but basically uh Sam used to
work at Jane Street uh trading from Wall
Street uh he was like yo I can make
money in crypto he subscribes to this
idea of effective altruism and basically
like make as much money as you can to do
as much good in the world as you can
yeah yeah
everyone's a liar
everyone's a liar I don't want to make
10 billion dollars to help people what a
[ __ ] load of [ __ ] all right so that's
what he said yeah and so he starts out
into that unbelievable Larry David you
[ __ ] goofy
so he starts out he's basically trading
back and forth you could buy Bitcoin on
one Exchange in America you could go
sell it in another country for a
different price he would just profit so
he found some Arbitrage there Arbitrage
I think it was in Japan like Japan yeah
yeah so he's just doing over and over
and over again that was the beginning of
Alameda research just think of it as a
trading firm right hedge funds hedge
fund trading firm okay and at some point
uh they were like hey it's good game but
like the exchanges that's even better
game and for people who don't know
anything about these exchanges one of
the key pieces is you have to have
liquidity so if you start an exchange
you need people to trade there right
because if people show up and they want
to trade like hey I'll sell Bitcoin but
no one wants to buy it then you're
screwed because you have to hold the
Bitcoin until someone else buys it you
just need buyers and sellers to meet
yeah and so you could do that a lot of
different ways you could be really good
at marketing and getting people there
you could have some sort of better
economics for people like an incentive
or whatever they had an ex exchange and
then they had the hedge funds they could
provide liquidity so it was a very
liquid Market early on so a lot of
people would show up it also didn't hurt
that a lot of people supposedly when
they were showing up were making a lot
of money so if you're a Trader and
you're like hey go trading all these
different exchanges but I always make
money on this one well this one sounds
like a good one it's kind of like a
sports book right if you're gambling all
the time and you're like oh but I always
win at this sports book we're going back
they get all your business right yeah so
that started to happen uh and real quick
in exchange is a place where people can
buy crypto sell crypto and also store
crypto right you're not supposed to
leave it there but yes people do leave
it on the exchanges uh because think
about it if you're trading especially
the Traders right if you're trading you
don't know if a couple hours from now
you're going to want to buy sell do
nothing whatever so you're going to take
it all the way off put it back up so you
leave it up there a lot of people leave
it right yeah yeah uh and so as this was
building up he built it into you know 32
billion dollar company FTX uh raise a
bunch of money had not really that many
employees couple hundred employees but
for 32 billion dollar company not that
many uh and then it like all fell apart
over the last two weeks and now people
are are waking up and they're like oh
[ __ ] like
they took away the alcohol no one's
drunk anymore on all the profits like
what the hell happened and that's where
we are okay so what did happen how did
they go from 32 billion dollars to
absolutely nothing that's pretty tough
yeah so remember 32 billion is basically
like a fake number right it's kind of
like uh if we all start a company
together and uh we come to you and we're
like uh our company's worth 100 million
and you give us a dollar and you say yes
it's worth 100 million dollars like now
we're like oh we have a 100 million
dollar company but like that's just
because we convinced you that it was
worth 100 million dollars right got you
so it's the evaluation so if it's worth
a hundred million dollars and I give you
a million dollars I own one percent of
that company correct at that evaluation
but like that valuation yeah somebody
else may be like it's not worth 100
million it's worth 50 million right
somebody else might be like you guys are
all morons that's a worthless company
this always happens on Shark Tank
correct guys come in and they've they
say you get 10 for a million dollars and
they're like you're you're giving
yourself a 10 million evaluation I don't
agree correct okay so 32 billion was the
valuation of the company itself which
people were giving real money they
invested billions of dollars but the 32
number wishes to value the company uh
and so what basically occurred was uh
people were giving them money on the
exchange to buy and sell uh crypto and
in their terms of service it said we
don't touch the coins that you give us
so if you have Bitcoin on our exchange
we leave it there if you have ethereum
we leave it there if you have stable
coins we leave it there we don't touch
it and so one of the things that does go
on in crypto it also goes on in
traditional Finance uh and we've talked
about on past episodes like if you put
your dollars in the bank what do they do
they lend it on the back right there are
crypto companies that do the same thing
but FTX said we don't do that and so
people believe them and so then it came
out making money how are they making
money they take a spread so like uh I
wanna uh sell Bitcoin you want to buy
the Bitcoin they take like a fee or
spread sometimes both and so uh it came
out that at some point over the last
couple of years uh uh Sam the FTX team
whoever allegedly was like oh why don't
we take the user funds and like bring it
over here to the hedge fund which is
Alameda correct and so it's unclear like
were that was there legal documentation
that it was alone did they just like
move it the degree of uh uh
intentionality versus they would
describe it as a mistake like you can
imagine there's a big bankruptcy filing
so like now lawyers are involved like
it's all going to come out yeah do we
know if they move the funds or if they
take a loan on the on the crater funds
what I think is clear is that like eight
billion dollars like wasn't where it was
supposed to be I think it's maybe the
best way to say it right and how it got
to the the wrong place I think there's a
uh some debating going on right now now
is is it I've read something about them
backing that let's call it a loan or
whatever it is with their own token yes
is that true because they had a token
right ftt is this is where it gets kind
of crazy so like imagine again go back
to that example we have a 100 million
dollar company that we all created we
got an investor to invested that
valuation and then he was like all right
cool like what are the assets of the
business and we're like well we have uh
some computers we have some desks and
then like we literally just have a stack
of papers that we just like ripped out
of a notebook and they're just sitting
here and like that's an asset and
they're like well what's it worth be
like well we sold some of those pieces
of paper to somebody else for a hundred
dollars a piece of paper
be like okay like why do they think it's
worth 100 well that's what the market
says it's worth
it's not paper they just created coins
like they literally just like got coins
that they created ftt now there was uh
an advantage if you held it so some of
these exchanges do have coins and what
they'll say is things like uh if you
have our coin uh you may get lower fees
on the exchange and they try to create
like value so you trade in your Bitcoin
for ftts and then they pay you to hold
the ftt casino kind of thing like a few
different exchanges did this I think uh
block five might be one of them yeah so
block five
[Laughter]
no I'm just saying you got me into
crypto so I have some idea of what
you're saying yeah which is rare and I
know different ways in which you [ __ ]
me so
[Laughter]
I still believe long term but you've you
know you [ __ ] me gently blocked by
doesn't have block fight doesn't have a
token but there are other actual
exchanges so binance has a token FTX had
a token Etc and uh what became kind of
weird is like if you control the money
supply essentially of ftt and you give
it to someone and you say hey uh I'll
give you 500 million dollars of this
token give me a loan or give me some
value I invest the token now I own
equity in your business like all these
different things pretty brilliant
actually if the token is worth what you
say it's worth okay it's crazy but like
okay the problem would eventually happen
is CZ CEO of binance was just like I
don't think that I'm gonna hold this
anymore and he tweeted it which like the
binance is another exchange exchange
yeah the biggest competitor of FTX
correct and it looks like he
intentionally tried to affect ftx's
bottom line or business or tank the
whole company it appears that way
CZ doesn't seem to be a stupid guy and
uh uh he basically had a kill shot and I
think he took it and why did he have a
kill shot like
they helped seed FTX years ago so he was
an investor and so he got bought out of
his position and he publicly said that
they got paid uh in stable coins and
some of these other tokens these ftt
tokens so he was sitting on like 500
million dollars worth of the token and
he realized and what he tweeted was just
like uh due to recent uh information
because there's an article that
coindeska published he goes uh we're
gonna be selling our position but we've
got 500 million dollars that's a big
position you tell people you're gonna
sell it well everyone else goes maybe
I'll sell before he sells
now I heard uh SBF Sam bankman freed uh
tried to buy the position at like 22 a
coin from what's his name is CZ CZ from
CZ and then CZ said no because he didn't
want to get purchased he wanted to flood
the market there was a public tweet from
the CEO of the hedge fund uh which again
this is where you start getting into a
little bit of conspiracy land like uh
why did she tweet 22 was the price of
the token at the time like was that an
important number
and so did they kind of reveal or tip
their hand and and so like the one thing
in crypto is like there are millions and
millions and millions of people around
the world that are playing this game
slash in this industry trading whatever
these people are not dumb yeah and so if
they think that there's an opportunity
to make money by uh arbitraging
something or by like basically screwing
somebody yeah in terms of like the
market like they're gonna at least try
yeah and so that's ultimately what
happened it unraveled the whole thing uh
and pretty much within like a week they
filed for bankruptcy and wasn't there a
leak that came through coindesk that
basically kind of blew all of it up
before the tweet and how did that leak
come out I don't know who leaked it um
what was the leak it was the balance
sheet of the hedge fund so like
basically saying like the hedge fund is
Alameda Alameda yeah like hey they have
all these assets but a lot of them are
in this token that is their token like
kind of like revealed more information
uh there's a guy Ian Allison at coindesk
who in my opinion like this is the story
of for sure the year if not probably the
decade uh when it comes to kind of this
new like digital world and uh he's not
gonna get as much credit as he should
but uh it wasn't like the mainstream
media it wasn't a regulator it wasn't
like somebody
supposedly from the industry leaked the
balance sheet to a reporter in the
industry he published it and then like
the free market took over interesting
right and then you have CZ he's kind of
swayed it a little like he kind of
started that run best of Mark he's a
market participant right it's kind of
like free market uh Dynamics uh play now
the sad part I think we should call it
is like a lot of people got hurt in this
right yeah and there's a lot of people
who lost money there's a lot of people
who got duped there's a lot of people
who thought this was one thing it turns
out it's not so like
free market is like this interesting
dynamic because like technically I've
said that like the free markets the
judge jury and executioner
but like there's collateral damage as
well and so this happens in finance to a
degree but if in finance let's say a
stock goes down too fast like remember
during covid like the stocks would be
falling like they look like [ __ ] coins
right yeah uh they have something called
um uh circuit breaker where if the stock
Falls I think it's like eight percent uh
they basically just say time out and the
stock stops trading for 15 minutes like
everyone catch your breath and then if
it falls again they stop it and then if
I think it's like 20 they shut off the
trading of that for the day
so it's not just this one day race to
the bottom yeah yeah so like very rarely
will you see it now now in aftermarket
trading there's all kinds of crazy stuff
that can happen but like there's
controls around the trading of the uh
assets because they've seen this stuff
happen in the past where things can go
from worth a lot to basically nothing in
seconds Now isn't that
an argument for regulation I know one of
the beautiful things about crypto and
one of the things that was so exciting
about it was that it was not regulated
it was not it didn't have like that
central bank system that we have here
and that freedom that people talk about
I'm sure you spoke about many times but
I feel like this experience right here
is a perfect example of where regulation
could have helped yeah there was two
things so first you can't confuse
Bitcoin with like all this other stuff
right so Bitcoin is a decentralized kind
of electronic peer-to-peer all this
other stuff is it's Finance yeah it's
fine no no but but it's like some more
similar to the dollar like a dollar 100
like what you were describing with FDT I
was thinking yeah how is that not Fiat
yeah it basically these people have
become central banks and the thing about
that is like if you are a central bank
you're going to need regulation in place
so they were central banks without
regulation and what would somebody do if
they just had a printing press for money
well it's even I think worse than that
so like Bitcoin is kind of in a league
of its own it is this decentralized
thing it I said isn't regulated right
like the dollar doesn't get put in jail
the dollar isn't fined it's the
companies and the organizations uh and
and the people who deal with dollars
they're regulated in the traditional
Financial so the asset is just an
inanimate object same with Bitcoin
Bitcoin just a system you can't regulate
it there's nobody to put well it is a
regulation right there's an amount
that I would call that right oh the code
Yeah the code basically says to be 21
million Bitcoin and maybe that's all you
need to create the value so it's like a
self-regulated the reason why it's the
most valuable is because it has a
regulator on it yeah it's decentralized
it's the most secure and also I think
that there's like the the least amount
of [ __ ] which I think is a really key
piece to this because what we'll see on
on this other stuff is like they just
recreated finance and I don't go as far
as maybe some of the the hardcore
Bitcoin like maximum people will go
they'll be like it's all worthless it's
all stupid it's all the stuff I just
look at it as like people are going to
create these Financial systems whether
we like it or yeah right they're going
to do it yeah but what the Central Bank
idea of like just creating your own
tokens to your point like there's no
disclosure rules at the same level that
there is in the Legacy Financial system
but FTX was regulated they had a
regulated entity in the United States
they had a regulated entity in the
Bahamas You could argue how good were
the regulations in either place should
they been better whatever but but
there's details coming out now that like
the Auditors didn't know this was
happening
so you kind of have to ask yourself like
if you go to a company you say send me
your audited financials and they send
them to you like what else do you want
this is like people you're an athlete
you can beat usada
you know what I mean like every every
year they find a way to get the roids in
the system without being detected and
they're like here I passed my drug test
it passed so they were passing the drug
test even though they were on the rights
they don't like right before you run the
100 meter dash at the Olympics they're
not like yo take the blood right now
right so like there's a little bit of
that going on which again more details
will come out and I think it's important
uh that we find that out over time but
also like the regulations don't always
stop bad people like if you remember
Bernie Madoff was regulated right so
part of Regulation which is which is
interesting is like if people are just
flat out lying
usually almost 100 of time they get
caught but what we find out is like
they're able to trick the rules or The
Regulators for some period of time and
so you can't just say oh if it's
regulated it's 100 all good and what I
think in this situation is that like
this grew so fast there were so many
different types of organizations
involved from investors to the people
they did commercials with like all the
stuff
people just were like
no one even asked the question of like
could the audited financials be wrong
could this information be wrong could
they just be potentially misleading
people